هذه الزياره
لجو بايدن
الى شوارع العاصمه كياف
في خطوه
في خطوه طبعا داعمه لكياف
نشاهد زيلينسكي
ويعني هناك
حراسه امنيه ومرافقه لعسكريين
محمد يعني نشاهد هذه الصور
ويمكنك معنى التعليق عليها لهذه الزياره
تاتي في ذكرى انتصار ثوره الميدان في
العشرين من فبراير وايضا تاتي قبل اربعه
ايام من الذكرى السنويه الاولى لبدء الغزو
الروسي للاراضي الاوكرانيه وايضا يعني
الدور الامريكي الكبير الذي لعبته
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في دعم
اوكرانيا اقتصاديا وعسكريا وخاصه يعني
خلال الفتره الماضيه التي شهدت اخذ ورد من
بعض الدول الاوروبيه ولعبت الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه دور كبير في اقناع
الشركاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي وفي حلف
الناتو لتزويد اوكرانيا ودعم اوكرانيا
بالعتاد والسلاح ولا ننسى انه ما يجري في
شرق اوكرانيا الان من هجوم كبير لروسيا
للقوات الروسيه على المناطق او على يعني
وحدات الجيش الاوكراني خاصه محاوله تطويق
والدخول الى مدينه يعني رساله كبيره رساله
دعم كبيره لاوكرانيا وللشعب الاوكراني
وللرنسكي